[Musique]
autrefois les musiciens du métro c'était
surtout les aveugles et les infirmes
[Musique]
à
enfin
c'est ça pour gagner ma vie c'est tout
qui sont pas contentes d'avoir guerre
qui sont pas sensibles aux données pour
mieux faire c'est que de voler ça fait
combien de temps vous êtes monsieur moi
j'aime bien je filme et roues depuis
plus de 25 ans alors oui et si ça ok
squelettiques pratiquement tôt
aujourd'hui signe des temps peut être de
vrais professionnels veulent faire du
métro un tremplin crois que je suis né
pour la musique
beaucoup de personnes s'attendaient à
rentrer chez eux comme d'habitude plus
ou moins fatigués et pof ils entendent
jouer ce qu'ils annoncent qu'ils
entendent qui sont dans des couloirs
c'est loin et qui qui cherche justement
dans lequel couloir disant temps de
cette musique
et il écoute
[Musique]
hu
ouah
oh
[Musique]
ça plaît à moi ça veut dire je ne suis
qu'un clochard
je suis né en france j'ai grandi en
france une fois les chanter dans une
langue étrangère
j'utilisais n'importe quoi au début par
louise canada goose bay louvre et puis
je me rendais compte que je vous disais
souvent la même chose
petit à petit je me suis dit il faut que
je vous raconte une histoire je me suis
dit que voilà tel ou tel bora français
voudrait dire tel ou tel mot ans est
directeur
[Musique]
bibeau et son bongo c'est l'exotisme
avec arnaud et gaël c'est surtout la
poésie
[Musique]
pavillon du
tursan bla
oh
[Musique]
moore est un passe-temps monde
est
content
[Musique]
monsieur pour
votre coeur ne manquent pas
vous avez pourtant
l'habitude
de sousse ont changé
croyez moi monsieur n'y revenez pas
croyez pas de moi
[Musique]
je
et
[Musique]
jamais
que d
[Musique]
les étrangers ne sont plus simplement de
passage peut aussi viennent tenter leur
chance à paris comme ces deux américains
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
vous avez quel âge tiléne moi je vends
des massages
vous êtes à paris depuis combien de
temps
cinquante jours
très exactement trice exact très
exactement deux mois sur lequel jouer
deux mois quatre jours demande quelques
jours ah oui c'est vrai
vous êtes arrivés à paris dans des
comptes dans quelles conditions et pour
quoi faire à
nous pensons d'être en condition riche
mais comme paris est plus cher que nous
avons pensé ce n'était pas du tout vrai
et on venait d'italie
parce qu'en italie on a fait tout ce
qu'on voulait faire on peut penser que
le public parisien est un bon public oui
ils sont piqués au vif a
comme le champagne contre en
comparaissant avec un bain blanc et
aussi sont assez libérale
moi je trouve les vieux spécialement
sont ils ont fait beaucoup de choses qui
sont très réceptifs aux nouveaux et vous
pensez quelque chose de commun entre eux
et la musique que vous leur proposez à
oui je me sens nous sommes tous humains
nous sommes tous vivants c'est déjà la
communication nous avons tous les mêmes
problèmes tous les jours de
lutter pour nous pour la liberté
qu'est-ce que vous chantez les
compositions d'autres compositeurs ou ce
que vous créez vous même la plupart sont
les nôtres ou deux mois route de nous
des roues de rohff pourquoi
parce qu'on a beaucoup de dire pour vous
jouer dans le métro s'est échappé au
système oui on non parce qu'on entend
dans un autre système c'est très
difficile c'est presque impossible de
chez de chapet du système et quel est
cet autre système un autre système ça
sera le système de métro le système des
flics qui viennent chez toi et de dire
ne pas jouer et de dire quelques fois
très gentil que ferait très brusque
quelquefois ils te poussent mais en même
temps fait c'est les les côtés sont plus
claires quand on joue dans la rue ou
dans le métro c'est nous ces deux dans
la système des disques des concerts
les manipulateurs essaie de vous faire
une partie de leur système et ses traits
il ya toujours le carotte devant le nez
[Musique]
j'ai commencé avec une autre est de 5
et puis pour me faire un nom je fais les
chanteurs dans une autre pièce très
connue en allemagne qui se plaît bien
rater et puis de la suite passé de
commencer de mieux plus grand plus grand
j'ai réussi à voir une pièce de 25
éléments et puis après c'est arrivé la
guerre je jouais pour les américains
américain avec cinq accords de 25 à 7
puis à 6 arrivé lentement à paris
le métro pour moi c'est une estrade
importants comme un théâtre parfaitement
et je te dis je vous dis franchement moi
j'utilise sont obligés d'étudier pareil
et gym est le même amour comme si je
devrais aller à faire une première c'est
pas moi au lido ou n'importe où parce
qu'ils sont très exigeants
c'est une bonne journée monsieur tony
est prêt
28,50 quelque chose comme ça pour moi
c'est très bien j'ai pas besoin de
beaucoup d'argent
quand j'ai repris ma pension que j'ai
coupé elles vont manger c'est tout quel
est votre plus jolis souvenirs dans le
métro les meilleurs le meilleur ça qui
est ça ma
c'est pas ça m'a rendu vraiment et ris
je pense et j'ai pensé à elle toute ma
vie encore on était au châtelet et et
bien c'est pas pour quelle raison et
nous avait signalé
alors tout d'un coup on avait beaucoup
de gens autour jeté avec un guitariste
et on était ensemble on était plein de
gens autour des lots tout d'un coup
cette arrivée de la police en civil ne
s'était pas bien on y forme et il vient
pour nous dire pas mauvais un espace
gentiment comme ça mais alors ils sont
presque ils se sont presque effectué
pour pour les gens il est pourquoi pour
pas dans un endroit qu'est ce qu'ils
font ils font rien comme ça mais vous
savez se défendit chacun cherchait des v
et puis tout d'un coup une jeune fille
elle c'est tout le débat vous fait voir
manquer ce que je pense de cette musique
conte salle on le sait tourner de
l'autre côté il y avait une femme
qu'elle vendait des violettes alors elle
va elle achète un bouquet de violettes
elle nous amène ses violettes à ce
moment là tout le monde se tourne ils
ont vidé la corbeille de cette femme
mais nous autres on était plein bourg et
des violettes dans parce que vous êtes
heureux c'est très content de ça
je pourrais pas m'imaginer une vie comme
avant vous avez toute artificielle comme
ça de recevoir des gens comme ça mais
moi j'aime d'être seul
d'embêter pas les idiots vous comprenez
les idiots qu'ils pensent que moi quand
je travaille dans les métros qui suit
moins que le gold
mois ci plus sur loire comme ça qu'avant
j'étais pas avoir du tout 2 t3
artificielle des droits parce que ça
fait de l'argent j'ai payé ça vous allez
voiture comme ça
durante il les musiciens du métro
l'affluence la sécurité des passagers
permettront-elles longtemps cette forme
de tolérance garderont nous longtemps
cette poésie du métro
[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]